we're on problem 116 what is the value
of a plus B squared statement one
statement one tells us that a times B is
equal to zero that to me seems fairly
fairly useless
let me see look what if we expand that
out that's equal to a squared plus 2 a B
plus B squared right this is the same
thing I just expanded out a plus B
squared and so they're giving us a piece
of telling us that this right here this
term right here is going to be equal to
zero right if a B is equal to zero this
term right here is going to be equal to
zero but we still don't know what a
squared + B squared are so statement 1
by itself not so useful statement 2 a
minus B squared is equal to 36 this is
interesting so let's expand let's expand
this out a little bit
so this says this tells us so you might
want to say oh that means that a minus B
is plus or minus 6 but actually I don't
think that is going to help you as much
well actually that could help you as
well but the way I'm thinking about it
is let's expand this out we get a
squared minus 2 a B minus 2 a B plus B
squared right is equal to 36 so by
itself the statement isn't that useful I
mean even here the statement says that
if you would take the square root of
both sides it tells us that the
difference between a and B is either
positive 6 or negative 6 if you took the
square root of both sides so statement 2
by itself is kind of useless but if you
use them together you expand out
statement 2 you get this now if we also
take in statement 1 and we say oh a B is
equal to 0 so then that is equal to 0
and we're left with a squared plus B
squared is equal to 36 and if a squared
plus B squared is equal to 36 then we
know that this a squared and plus B
squared is also equal to 30
six right so that tells us that a plus B
a plus B squared is equal to 36 as well
so both statements together are
sufficient and this is interesting
because if you think about it makes a
lot of sense this statement tells us
that the difference between a and B and
this is all a waste of time but I just
want to give you some intuition this
tells us that a minus B is equal to plus
or minus six all right so tells you that
the difference between a and B is either
positive six or minus six so that one is
six bigger than the other but we don't
know which way it goes
this statement tells us that one of them
is equal to zero right both of them
aren't going to be equal to zero because
there's a six difference right so one of
them if one of them is equal to zero
then the other one is either going to be
plus or minus six right and if only if
we look at here if we look at this
statement one of these numbers is zero
the other one is plus or minus six but
it doesn't matter if one is zero and one
is plus six when you square it you get
36 if one is zero and the other it's not
minus six you square it you get 36
so I just want to give you that little
intuition but the correct answer is that
both statements together are necessary
to solve this problem 117 the more
connections you can make while doing
these math problems the better you'll be
really better off you'll be in life I
think and I'll start making sense all
right they've drawn this thing this okay
and then they draw this down like that
now let's see this is l m n and k and
the figure above what is the ratio of K
n to M n so they want to know the ratio
of this side KN to MN k and to M and
fair enough okay
statement number one tells us the
perimeter of rectangle k l m n the
perimeter of rectangle kam is 30 meters
so perimeter is equal to 30 meters so
this is a rectangle right so what does
this tell that tells us that you know
let's put it in terms of the things we
care about that two times MN all right
because MN & KL are going to be the same
length since rectangle so this tells us
that two times M n plus 2 times K n
because KN and L M are the same length
so this just put in the terms of the
things we care about plus two times K n
so 2 times KN is equal to 30
that's the perimeter twice this plus
twice this is the perimeter you could
say that Plus that Plus that Plus that
but this keeps it in terms of that so
what I think well I think we can sort
let's divide both sides by the divide
both sides by 2 you get m n plus K n is
equal to equal to 30 and actually yes
you still can't figure out the ratio
between the two you just have you just
know it that the sum of the two are
equal to 30 let's look at statement two
right you can't figure out the ratio
from this statement two tells us the
three small rectangles have the same
dimensions the three small rectangles
have the same dimensions this is
interesting
so that's telling us well this this
that's interesting because that tells us
that whatever that tells us that this
distance and this distance have to be
the same that tells us that that tells
us that and if this distance and this
distance is the same then this distance
right there is twice this distance how
did I get that well this distance is
twice each of this these distances right
this longer side of this horizontal
rectangle is twice this and this is the
same thing as this so for all of these
rectangles their ratio of their sides is
kind of is one to two is the ratio of
the sides so let's create a unit called
the short side of this rectangle right
so how many units long is MN well MN is
going to be this side right here it's
going to be two of those units long so
one two and then three
right and we figured that out because
the long side of this is twice as long
as a short side so if we were measuring
these in terms of the short sides of the
rectangle and men is three of them and
then KN is two of them one two right one
two so the ratio of of KN to MN we just
it doesn't matter what units you measure
and you just want to get the ratio so
the ratio is going to be equal to two to
three so statement two alone is
sufficient to solve this problem next
question
118 if N is a positive integer is 150
over n an integer so it's essentially
asking us is n divisible into 150 that's
the only way that 150 over N is going to
be an integer statement number one tells
us that n is less than seven now if
every number less than 7 is divisible
into 150 then we're all set because we
know it's positive as well
we know it's positive so and one works
right to work seventy-five three works
fifty-four let's see you go for into
this four goes into 100 and then does it
go into fifty four goes into 50 no it
doesn't go into fifty so four does not
work so just by telling us that n is
less than seven does not solve the
problem because if n was four four does
not go into 150 evenly it goes into it
well I'm not gonna figure it out four
goes into it what 19 it goes into twenty
five twenty five plus twelve thirty
seven point five times so that doesn't
do us any good so statement 1 by itself
doesn't isn't that useful statement two
and is a prime number n is prime so this
statement by itself is not useful
because I mean n could be a prime number
larger than 150 so that by itself
doesn't tell us that we we definitely
can get an integer and and could easily
be Y or it could be three which would
allow it so n doesn't tell you one way
or another whether this is an integer
but if you combine this do statements if
you say that N is a prime number that
has to be less than seven then we can
take four out of the picture because
four isn't prime and then you put five
there five definitely does go into 150
and then six six does go into 150 it
goes into 120 and leave 30 left over so
six goes into 120 so all of the prime
numbers less than seven are divisible
into 150 so both statements combined are
sufficient to answer this question see
in the next video